just as important as the final answer
we're gonna end up with I'm going to
also emphasize the way in which we she's
headed out it's not like there's just
one right way to set things out but
there are better ways there are clearer
ways and there are ways that are more
obscure and harder to understand for
others we want to be able to get the
answer we also want to communicate right
outside now when we take an equation
like this to solve these equations and
to be fair I didn't say this word solve
up the top but we knew that what we
wanted to do we want to get all of the
pruning rules on one side yeah that's
the target okay so you've got them on
both sides at the moment that was the
new challenge you met recently so what's
an operation I could do to both sides
that would make it so I don't have
pronumerals on both sides I just have
them on one Jessica with you okay
I'm going to subtract a from both sides
that's my idea okay so I'm writing it
there just so I don't have it stuck in
my head now I'm gonna do it to the left
then I'll do it to the right I currently
have three A's so after I take Jessica's
suggestion how many A's will be left
David - fantastic
what happened 16 yeah I haven't touched
it so it's just still staying put yeah
that's the left-hand side what's the
right-hand side going to look for here
yeah just the 18 because I subtracted
the a good and at this point I've got
all my pro numerals on one side that's
fantastic but there's other stuff that I
don't want that the 16 is this so David
Joyce yes why should do fantastic minus
16 again I'm gonna write this over here
on the right hand side so I know what
I'm doing to a gets left on the left
hand side right hand side is equal to
fantastic one last step what do I want I
don't want two ways I just want one of
them Krishan you haven't said a few yet
/ - fantastic last step divide that by
two and then I'll have my final answer a
equals to one okay now just a quick
check one of the things that you can do
to ensure that your solution is correct
is you can just check it out in the
original line of the question okay if we
think a is 1 does it make sense of the
original line 3 lots of 1 + 16 3 lots of
1 plus 16 is 19 fantastic
on the right-hand side one plus 18 also
19 so checks out
wonderful okay let's have a go and this
one now someone who hasn't said anything
yet can I get a suggestion for our first
operation could be any takers hmm
Vishakha did you have a sort of half
handout to really give us a go and then
Merrick maybe you can give us the next
line after after Vishakha yeah
- our was a suggestion said against
right
is it a + or nice that's a great
question can anyone help us out we're
trying to think about again the
pronumerals right should we add or
should we subtract Mac what do you think
okay excellent so as Merrick has pointed
out and perhaps you're working did not
look exactly like this that's because
there are many ways through this
question we could subtract you are from
both sides that would get all the odds
over here or we could add 5r to both
sides that would get the odds all over
here which do you prefer what do you
reckon we generally like to have the Pro
numeral on the left I mean it's an
equation both sides are the same but
there's one other thing I like about the
left hand side let's actually do it and
I'll show you what it is
I'm going to add 5 to both sides and if
you haven't written what you're doing on
the side there I encourage you to do so
we're gonna get em to end up with 7 r +
18 which equals yep then negative 3 okay
now let me now justify for you why I
prefer this ever so slightly to the
other way
how many R's are over there on the left
so there's there's a single time I've
written it but I said 7 lots of that so
there are 7 hours there yeah 7 is the
number at the front now if I'd done the
other thing if I'd subtracted 2 R from
both sides the odds would be all over
here but how many would I have wouldn't
have seven of them would I
I'd have minus seven there's nothing
wrong with that it's still correct but I
like to avoid negative numbers wherever
I can there's just an an extra way for
errors to creep in I always forget I
make mistakes and negatives so I'm going
to try and avoid them okay another step
what can I do both sides and
you've just given me an answer so can I
get someone else it yeah go ahead
- 18 okay so that's going to leave us
with seven are over on the left
yeah negative 21 by the way it's a minor
thing but it's worth point yeah I'm
saying negative 21
because negatives an adjective it's a
it's an attribute a way to describe a
number whereas - is an operation it's
something that it's a verb it's
something that happens okay final step
I'm just gonna give you this one for
free we should divide by 7 and that
gives us our final answer which is
negative 3 and just like before you
could pop that in the top and it will
still work out - lots of negative 3 is
negative 6 at 18 you get 12 gonna work
out here as well okay does anyone have
any questions on that were you feeling
okay with that
if you are please make this subheading
adding the word I'm gonna be having
missing here is brackets now some of you
because you're super well prepared for
intern to exercise 1004 you don't need
to right now I'm gonna put everything
when you're up on the board the heading
of exercise 1004 is equations with
brackets but the reason why I haven't
called this that is because we're
solving equations all the way through
they're not like different kinds of
things they've just got extra little
bits and pieces in them okay so what
we're gonna do is really have a look at
here is one a so I'm gonna do this one
for free for you you can jump down with
me and then I want us to think about the
two ways we can go about solving these
equations that have brackets thrown in
so here's the first one there's a two
here come the brackets and then I think
it's an 18 no it's an 8 okay now I'm
going to suggest that there are at least
some there's probably more but there are
at least two ways to go about this would
anyone like to take any stab in the dark
for what one of the ways could be noise
oh yeah
okay can we keep pause on that right so
America come to you in a second to give
me the next thought but let's make sure
we understand what those are saying two
times a thing is equal to eight but I
know what thing to multiply two by two
get a it should be four which is correct
I'm another way you can think about that
through this kind of thing what's the
operation that always is doing to both
sides that gives you four it's dividing
by two very good so this number at the
front of brackets we can actually divide
everything by that let's write that down
and then americo get your thought x plus
three
i've divided everything on the left hand
side by two and that gives me dividing
everything on the right hand side by 2
which is 4 we're going to say that
America is something different ok okay
so let's let's go down this line in a
second I do want to finish this line of
working and then I'm gonna suggest
that's what we're going to put over here
ok can we work out what X is here what's
the operation we're going to do both
sides yeah
the answer is 1 because we're going to
subtract 3 from both sides
subtract 3 from both sides that gives us
an answer okay now what Marik is
suggesting is trying to get rid of the
brackets over here on the left-hand side
we have a name for that by the way
getting rid of the brackets what we call
it so that's with an e expanding Regan's
ahead it so if I were to expand this
right I'm gonna take the 2 and I can
multiply by everything on the inside yet
you agreed that so I'll have firstly two
lots of X plus 2 lots of 3 which as you
said is 6 okay have I done anything to
the right hand side is point I I just
kind of left the right hand side I
didn't do anything to it yet I'll write
that 8 there and now as we saw before
I'm like oh I have other stuff here on
the left hand side I don't want it I'm
gonna subtract 6 from both sides that
gives me 2x okay at this point am I
finished one more thing to do I should
divide by two very good idea and x
equals one just like we saw before so
that's encouraging
whichever way I went I got the same
answer now which do we prefer let's give
some names to these okay Marik's
strategy was expanding the brackets
bless you expanding brackets okay what
Louise did was first she divided right
so I'm just gonna call this one dividing
by factor the fact that we divided by
was two right now which do we prefer I'm
just going to look at the board
we should you prefer in this case you
prefer expanding brackets I'm interested
why do you prefer who prefers expanding
brackets hands up
okay people who have their hands up just
eyeball it yep hands down can someone
give me a reason why they like that that
method David what's your thought it's
got more working it looks more
impressive when I put the way here is
then have a different reason
Mme it uses better algebra I'm
interested by that one I don't know
exactly what better algebra means are
you defined that maybe one more
suggestion Enoch can you give me a
thought okay that's it right okay so
here's that for a second we could do
this for a bit longer but let's take all
these thoughts and gather them expanding
brackets is a good way to go
if you've got lots of brackets and
you're not sure what else to do with
them and the first thing I want to do is
eliminate them right
the fewer brackets there are there's
simpler problem is to deal with in fact
did we not just turn this problem which
has got more stuff in it into one of
these kinds of problems which you
already know how to do do you agree once
the brackets out of the way it's just
like one of the old problems we're set
this many times in max a lot of the
maths that we focus on is converting a
hard problem to look like one we already
know how to do which is much easier and
that's kind of what expanding does now
I'm I'm actually not everyone put up
their hands before but I'm actually
going to say for this particular
question I prefer this method now does
anyone agree with me okay I'm like some
people
up there hands twice okay I'm Harry why
do you for this question
prefer this one it's yeah it's simpler
so this is kind of like the reverse of
David I thought this does look fancier
but when there's less you can do it
faster and there's less room for error
just could you have a different reason
[Music]
right okay so there's a speed issue
there right if it's simpler
generally it is easier to do it quicker
Krishan did you want out one lasts
different reason ah very good so let's
just have a look at this question you
don't need to write this part down just
leave it as it is but suppose I change
this it's like a 7 right so this is kind
of what Marek was anticipating before
does 7 go neatly into 2 it doesn't but I
can still do the same thing that I did
before with this I can just still / - I
won't get 4 what will I get
3.5 I get three in a house I'll get X
plus three equals three and a half and I
can I can still do it just like I did
before now maybe you feel like gross
fractions okay number one we all have to
be comforted with fractions number two
sometimes the answer will have a
fraction in it no matter what you do
okay
but the key thing that I want you to get
across is that you've got both of these
tools at your disposal